though progress has been made on several
vaccine candidates none have been
approved yet by the fda
but southern nevada healthcare workers
are making sure they're ready for when
that time comes
8 news now reporter kate houston joins
us live in the newsroom now after going
to a covet 19
vaccine training event today kate sasha
healthcare workers from different
organizations are coming together to
ensure the vaccination process goes
smoothly
today's exercise went through the
logistics of how to get a large volume
of people vaccinated efficiently
and safely the southern nevada health
district held the exercise during a flu
clinic
due to social distancing guidelines
people will need to be spaced
far apart when getting the kovid 19
vaccine since this vaccine is new
there will also need to be an
observation area where people will be
monitored for 15 minutes afterwards
the health district tells me the vaccine
will be distributed
on a tiered approach health care workers
firefighters police
and critical personnel will be
vaccinated first
we're going to need to get them in and
we want to get them a large volume
quickly so really what we're looking
exercising today is to look for
bottlenecks and then
if we need to open up more vaccination
lanes
you know do the design layout a little
differently
quinn says in order to move to the next
tier of people
80 percent of the group needs to be
vaccinated he's confident though that
this process will be done quickly
the southern nevada health district is
planning more vaccine exercises in the
near future
the next one will focus on how they'll
send data back in real time